i have to ask you about the ice thing
had you ever done anything like that
before the ice bath no it was i didn't
know if you played sports graham because
i feel like in sports people do look at
your face
oh my god have you ever done that have
you ever have one of my house not this
brand but we have a cold plunger jimmy
or address
send me one of these yes amazing yeah
wait so they're supposed to be really
good for you they're incredible oh
really good for your health did you like
i found once i was in it like i woke up
like that it was amazing and of course
you feel like um like you can't breathe
right and like all of your insides are
shriveling up but other than that it's
great oh yeah you know what sign me up
nick did you feel good
you feel really rejuvenated i did yeah i
felt rejuvenated and i i do it probably
once a week because it's really good for
inflammation it is and wow you know
maybe you know nights that get away from
you have one too many glasses of wine
it's good for them
yeah you're who sends people tequila
that's your problem um it's good have
you ever done it i have i have done it
once as a like and for like a second
like when you're in high school i jumped
in one of like the player's ice baths i
was like no
but then i watched this whole thing on
how good that is for your body your
heart like
like there's so many things that that's
good for um and i i don't know i've
never done it but i've always wanted one
but then i thought am i that la tool
that's like as an ice bath
wow
that's two kelly that's two
fake colin hanks
[Music]
you